à toutes et à tous merci de votre
présence nous poursuivons nos auditions
avec en cette fin d'après-midi
l'audition de Madame Chine Labbé de
newsgard
redafissan chef et vice-présidente en
charge des partenariats Europe et Canada
de cette société américaine créée par
des journalistes pour évaluer la
fiabilité des sites d'information et
d'actualité en septembre dernier votre
organisme a mis en lumière donc vous
préciserez cela que d'après votre
analyse 20% des vidéos qui apparaissent
dans les résultats de recherche du
réseau Tik Tok sur les principaux sujets
d'actualité contiendraient de la més
information comment expliquer vous cette
ce que vous constatez vous comme comment
expliquez-vous ce pourcentage est-ce que
c'est une sur-reprétation par rapport à
d'autres
réseaux que le réseau Tik Tok est-ce du
selon vous au fait qu'il s'agirait d'une
jeune société débordée par son succès
d'une mise en avant délibérée de contenu
susceptibles de retenir l'attention des
utilisateurs ou encore d'un outil de
la grande et au service de qui
pourrez-vous nous dire si vous
connaissez la manière dont TikTok
organise justement sa modération
pensez-vous que Tik Tok qui vient d'être
désigné comme une des très grandes
plateformes en ligne sous supervision
directe de la Commission européenne sera
en capacité de respecter les obligations
qui lui seront imposées par le Règlement
sur les services numériques et nous
allons donc laisser la parole pour un
exposé liminaire et peut-être
pourrez-vous à nous préciser si newsgard
a des liens d'intérêt avec la plateforme
tip-toc dans la mesure où celle-ci fait
appel à des prestataires comme l'AFP
pour vérifier la véracité des
informations peut-être me dire aussi ce
que vous entendez par mes informations
par rapport à une fausse information ou
à une infox et nous préciser votre votre
approche et votre méthode de travail
avant de vous laisser la parole je me
dois procéder au formalité d'usage dans
le cas d'une commission d'enquête je
dois vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant la commission est passible des
peines prévues articles 434 13 14 et 15
du code pénal et je vous invite donc à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
avec la vérité en levant la main droite
et en disant je le jure
je le jure merci madame vous avez la
merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur charmant de la commission
d'enquête merci de me recevoir
aujourd'hui et de vous pencher sur le
sujet qui est le mien à savoir celui de
la présence de mes informations et de
désinformation sur la plateforme que
vous examinez Tik Tok alors je me
présente effectivement devant vous cet
après-midi pour représenter newsgard une
société qui lutte contre la més
information et la désinformation en
comme le disait monsieur le Président en
analysant la fiabilité décide
d'information et qui produit aussi des
rapports sur les tendances de la més
information et de la désinformation en
ligne sur ces sites que nous suivons de
près mais aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
à l'origine Tik Tok était surtout connu
pour sa composante musicale on y
trouvait principalement des vidéos de
karaoké de danse certains représentants
de la société continue à en parler comme
d'une application de divertissement et
de joie mais votre commission comprend
bien pourquoi une entreprise comme la
nôtre qui étudie la mes informations et
la désinformation suit de près ce qui se
passe sur tik car si l'application
chinoise est en effet un lieu de
divertissement c'est aujourd'hui bien
plus que cela c'est un endroit où les
utilisateurs vont chercher des
informations et comme tous les réseaux
sociaux où se partagent des informations
c'est un lieu où circule de nombreuses
infox y compris sur des sujets
politiques sociaux et géopolitiques et
la raison de s'y intéresser c'est aussi
sa taille et sa croissance
exceptionnelle TikTok est une plateforme
vous le savez plébisciter par les jeunes
30% des utilisateurs en France ont moins
de 18 ans selon Bloomberg c'est une
plateforme qui jouit aujourd'hui de 1,7
milliards d'utilisa d'utilisateurs
actifs dans le monde contre seulement 85
millions début 2018
et en 2021 Tik Tok et même passé devant
Google en tant que cycle plus visité sur
Internet selon cloudfer même si là
depuis perdu ce titre pour repasser en
troisième position alors partons de ce
constat nous avons mené plusieurs
expériences sur Tik Tok et publier
plusieurs rapports que je serai ravie de
vous décrire plus en détail lors des
questions notamment en ce qui concerne
la méthodologie mais pour ce propos
liminaire je vous voulez insister sur
deux observations principales il existe
en effet à mes yeux deux principaux
problèmes liés à la més information sur
TikTok d'abord le problème du scroll
lorsque les utilisateurs se contentent
de faire des vidéos sur leur film for
you et ensuite le problème de la
recherche qui est lié au moteur de
recherche de Tik Tok dans les deux cas
avec ces deux pratiques les utilisateurs
sont confrontés à de fausses
informations sur tous les grands sujets
d'actualité d'après nos analyses
commençons par le scroll puisque c'est
l'utilisation principale de
l'application et la manière avec les
utilisateurs acceptent principalement au
contenu la question à laquelle nous
avons tenté de répondre et la suivante
combien de temps faut-il à un
utilisateur pour tomber sur des contenus
faux ou trompeur sur des grands sujets
d'actualité tout simplement en scrollant
nous avons donc fait le test à deux
reprises en septembre 2021 avec le
covid-19 et en mars 2022 avec la guerre
en Ukraine dans les deux cas en faisant
faire le test à plusieurs analystes dans
plusieurs pays et dans plusieurs langues
la réponse à laquelle nous sommes
parvenus et moins de 40 minutes dans
notre expérience sur les contenus liés
au covid-19 par exemple un garçon
francophone de 13 ans qui a effectué le
test sous surveillance parentale c'est
vu montrer une vidéo satirique sur le
sujet du covid 19 en 17 secondes
seulement après cette connectée à l'App
et 20 minutes plus tard une vidéo le
mettant en garde contre un nouvel ordre
mondial est apparu dans son flux qui
affirmait je cite que la rappeuse
française Keny Arkana avait tout compris
lorsque 10 ans auparavant elle chantait
et je cite encore que les gouvernements
étaient en train de préparer le terreau
hors pair du plus grand génocide juste
pour businesser un tas de vaccins
empoisonnés et après environ une
demi-heure sur TikTok ce jeune
adolescent était exposé quasi
exclusivement à de la més information
sur le sur le covid-19 y compris des
contenus en tuvaques antivac c'est des
théories du complot anti-gouvernement
dans notre expérience sur la guerre en
Ukraine moins de 29 minutes après avoir
rejoint Tik Tok un analyste francophone
s'est vu montrer une vidéo d'un discours
de Vladimir Poutine dans lequel celui-ci
disait je cite ce n'est pas pour que les
néonazides aujourd'hui prennent le
pouvoir que vos perv vos grands-pères
vos arrières grand-père se sont battus
contre les nazis et en moins de 36
minutes le même analyse c'est lui
montrer une vidéo affirmant que je cite
toutes les images de cette pseudo guerre
sont fausses alors 40 minutes cela peut
sembler beaucoup mais si l'on rapporte
cette durée autant quotidien passé sur
Tik Tok en moyenne par les utilisateurs
c'est en réalité bien peu et cela veut
dire que tous les utilisateurs peuvent
être confrontés quotidiennement à de
fausses informations en effet le temps
moyen passé sur Tik Tok était de 95
minutes par utilisateur et par jour en
2022 selon melt water et le temps est
encore plus important si on regarde
seulement les plus jeunes utilisateurs
alors évidemment cela ne veut pas dire
qu'un utilisateur de Tik Tok ne va être
confronté qu'à de fausses informations
sur la plateforme le mélange des genres
est d'ailleurs assez détonnant sur Tik
Tok une fausse information va arriver
entre un même amusant et des
informations fiables
sur sur des sujets d'actualité mais le
design de l'application le fait de faire
défiler les vidéos les unes derrière les
autres sans réel mise en contexte ou
hiérarchisation et avec très peu de
labellisation des contenus fait qu'il
est extrêmement difficile pour un
utilisateur de faire le tri parmi les
informations qui vont lui être proposées
alors ça c'est le problème que j'appelle
du scroll ensuite vient le second
problème que je voulais souligner
aujourd'hui celui de la recherche sur
Tik Tok car oui Tik Tok sert aujourd'hui
de plus en plus de moteurs de recherche
à de nombreux internautes les
internautes vont chercher tout type
d'informations sur Tik Tok le dernier
restaurant à la mode la crème la plus
efficace mais ils vont aussi chercher
des informations sur l'actualité selon
une étude du pur Research Center environ
un quart des utilisateurs américains de
moins de 30 ans cherchent régulièrement
des informations sur Tik Tok alors la
question à laquelle nous avons tenté de
répondre et la suivante lorsqu'un
utilisateur effectue une recherche sur
Tik Tok quelle proportion de vidéos dans
les premières remontées à l'issue de sa
recherche contiennent de fausses
informations on a donc fait le test en
septembre 2022 en effectuant des
recherches liées à des sujets
d'actualité variés l'Ukraine le covid-19
les vaccins anticovid les fusillades aux
États-Unis et le résultat est le suivant
près de 20% des vidéos apparues dans les
20 premiers résultats de recherche sur
TikTok contenaient de fausses
informations par exemple la recherche
d'élection de 2020 a-t-elle été volée
renvoyée vers 6 vidéos contenant de
fausses allégations sur l'élection de
Joe Biden aux États-Unis parmi les 20
premiers résultats au contraire la
plupart des résultats pour la même
recherche sur Google étaient des
articles démantant la légation selon
laquelle l'élection de 2020 aurait été
volée et aucun de ces résultats ne
relayaient de fausses informations et
lorsqu'ils ne contenait pas de fausses
informations les résultats sur TikTok
étaient c'est intéressant de le
souligner souvent plus polémique que sur
Google peut-être
problématique encore non seulement
l'application met en avant de nombreuses
vidéos contenant de fausses affirmations
dans ces premiers résultats de recherche
mais elle suggère aussi des termes
tendancieux pour compléter une recherche
neutre par exemple lorsqu'un de nos
analystes à effectuer une recherche pour
le terme climat changement climatique
l'application lui a suggéré de chercher
climat change d'ibanks le changement
climatique démystifié planète change
dans un existe le changement climatique
n'existe pas même chose pour bout de
chat cette ville ukrainienne qui a été
le théâtre de massacre l'application
suggéré boutchah fake faux en référence
au faux récit selon lesquelles ces
massacres auraient en fait été mise en
scène par l'Ukraine entraînant donc dans
ces deux cas et dans d'autres cas que
nous avons étudié l'utilisateur vers
davantage encore de contenu faux ce
qu'il est important de comprendre c'est
que dans les deux cas qu'il s'agisse du
scroll ou du moteur de recherche ce sont
les algorithmes de Tik Tok qui sont
responsables de la présence fréquente de
contenu faux puisque ce sont eux qui
déterminent nouvelle vidéo vont
apparaître dans votre fil d'actualité et
lesquels vont remonter dans votre barre
de recherche je ne suis pas une
spécialiste des algorithmes et je sais
que vous avez eu une audition très
pertinente sur le sujet avec Marc Fadoul
je ne passerai donc pas beaucoup de
temps sur cette question mais je voulais
juste terminer en disant que je partage
son constat que ces algorithmes sont
véritablement les gardiens de
l'information en ligne et le cœur du
problème si l'on devait faire passer un
examen de résistance à la més
information à l'application chinoise il
y a peu de doutes qu'elle échouerait et
sur ce sujet comme sur beaucoup d'autres
c'est la conception algorithmique qui en
est la responsable avant d'ouvrir aux
questions j'aimerais par ailleurs
ajouter que je n'ai pas parlé des
contenus synthétiques ou manipulés par
intelligence artificielle sur la
plateforme les règles d'utilisation de
Tik Tok imposent que ces contenus soit
labellisés comme tel mais le fait que ce
n'est pas toujours le cas et que de
nombreuses vidéos manipulées circulent
sans label sur l'application et dans un
monde où il y a progresse rapidement
démocratisant la création de contenu
altéré
c'est une problématique qui ne doit pas
être négligée et je suis sûre que nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler dans les
questions et juste peut-être vous m'avez
posé la question de nos liens d'intérêt
avec Tik Tok nous n'avons pas de
relation commerciale avec Tik Tok
et sur la sur ce que vous dessinez comme
une mes informations
alors les infos sa formation parce que
déjà qu'entre l'anglais et le français
l'infox pourrait et devrait être utilisé
bon escient plutôt que la fake news sauf
que la fake news il y a quand même une
connotation de manière très américain
Ken et propre aux Américains donc on
peut peut-être utiliser les deux j'en
sais rien et sur la mes informations des
informations infox comme vous faites
le terme Fox plutôt que fake news
effectivement parce que je le terme fake
news comme vous le savez est devenu très
politique et donc pour moi un terme qui
n'a plus beaucoup de sens aujourd'hui
puisqu'il peut être utilisé pour pour
décrire des contenus tout à fait
crédible et valable mais qui ne vont pas
dans un sens politique
donné en revanche la différence oui
entre la mes informations et la
désinformation c'est que derrière la
désinformation il y a une volonté
malveillante une volonté de diffuser ses
contenus faux à dessin ça peut être pour
des raisons politiques géopolitique
financière par rapport du gain parce que
ça fait du clic
la més information c'est plutôt la
diffusion de fausses informations
peut-être par manque de rigueur
journalistique ça peut être une erreur
d'un média qui est fiable par ailleurs
mais cela dit aujourd'hui nous on dit
toujours qu'on travaille sur la més
information et la désinformation parce
que les deux s'imbriquent très souvent
c'est souvent difficile de de savoir
comment une campagne a commencé et si
certaines campagnes de désinformation
sont clairement des campagnes de
désinformation parce qu'elles sont
relayées par des médias d'État étrangers
il y a beaucoup de fausses informations
qui circulent sans que l'on sache
exactement où ça a commencé et pour
quelle raison avec elle avec elle dessin
merci beaucoup de cette introduction qui
va directement au coeur du sujet et qui
va nous permettre d'avancer à partir des
questions que les uns les autres nous
avons vous posé mais avant de vous poser
des questions je voudrais vous dire
bravo alors je sais pas si c'est à vous
personnellement qu'il faut dire bravo
mais je veux dire moi je suis content
que qu'une
entreprise comme newsgard existe parce
qu'il y en a pas assez il en faudrait
beaucoup plus et même je dirais la
disproportion entre les moyens des
plateformes
et
l'ampleur de la més information et de la
désinformation et le nombre de factures
je sais pas si on peut vous si vous vous
qualifiez de chaque Checkers
de ça vous êtes aussi en matière
d'éducation etc mais je voudrais vous
dire que ça fait plaisir de voir que un
certain qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont
aujourd'hui qui qui s'attache à ce à ce
sujet parce que ça nous paraît
pas seulement pour Tik Tok bien entendu
mais en général un des problèmes majeurs
y compris un des problèmes démocratiques
de l'existence que qu'implique
l'existence des réseaux sociaux
la première question que je voudrais
vous poser vous avez tout à l'heure
alors peut-être on pourrait justement
revenir sur le point de vue général de
newsgard est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
avez des partenariats et notamment des
partenariats avec des institutions
telles que le service vigilant en France
ou le service d'action extérieure
d'actions extérieures est-ce que vous
travaillez
avec un certain nombre de régulateurs un
certain nombre de d'organismes
nationaux européens
[Musique]
j'ai peut-être d'abord vous expliquer
quelle est notre modèle économique et
ensuite détailler si nous avons des
relations avec ces avec ces acteurs là
donc nous sommes effectivement une
entreprise commerciale et nous vendons
en fait des licences d'accès à nos
données à différents acteurs de
différentes entreprises
nous travaillons notamment avec des
plateformes numériques qui vont pouvoir
se servir de nos données ou donner accès
à nos données elles-mêmes à leur à leurs
utilisateurs avec des acteurs de
l'industrie publicitaire aussi que ce
soit des annonceurs
des agences publicitaires des chercheurs
qui travaillent sur le sujet de la mes
informations et de la désinformation des
agrégateurs de contenu des sociétés de
gestion de la réputation etc donc nos
clients sont très variés
effectivement nous avons
une petite passion une petite portion de
nos revenus qui viennent de d'entités
gouvernementales dans des démocraties
occidentales
en général en général toutefois c'est
c'est donc nos principales bases de
données pour lesquelles nous vendons des
licences d'accès sont d'abord nos
analyses de la fiabilité des sites
d'information donc nous avons analysé la
fiabilité des sites d'information dans 9
pays donc plus de 8500 sites et par
ailleurs un catalogue des principales
infox qui circulent en ligne avec à
chaque fois des hashtags associés des
mots clés etc pour ce qui est des
entités gouvernementales dans les
démocraties occidentales toutefois ce
travail n'est pas lié à nos évaluations
de la fiabilité des sites mais il s'agit
de donner spécifique sur la
désinformation provenant des tas
étrangers notamment de la Russie de la
Chine du Venezuela etc et donc c'est
vraiment sur l'identification de ces
campagnes là vous m'interrogiez sur
vigilum nous avons eu des échanges avec
vigime par le passé
mais nous n'avons pas de relation active
avec eux et nous avons pas de nous
n'avons pas de partenariat commercial
nous leur envoyons nos rapports comme
nous en voyons nos rapports à beaucoup
d'autres
représentants d'organismes tatiques
à des membres du Parlement européen à
des membres de la Commission européenne
et aussi au service européen d'action
extérieurs mais là encore nous n'avons
pas de partenariat commercial avec le
Service européen d'action extérieur ce
que je peux dire sur l'Europe toutefois
c'est que nous sommes membres de l'idmo
qui est l'Observatoire italien des
médias numériques qui est financé par
l'Union européenne et nous sommes
également membre du Code de bonnes
pratiques qu'on la contre la
désinformation nous sommes donc
signataires de ce code aux côtés des
grandes plateformes et aux côtés
d'autres entreprises de la société
civile et Decker depuis la révision du
code en juin dernier
merci beaucoup
au passage ce n'est pas une question
mais j'ai relevé votre proposition de
nous
communiquer un certain nombre de
rapports que vous que vous édité et qui
pourrait intéresser le sujet de notre
commission donc je vous confirme ainsi
que les administrateurs et sénateurs ici
présents que nous sommes tout à fait
pour une heure
de ces rapports si vous aussi vous
voulez bien nous les faire parvenir
vous avez parlé de de la confection
algorithmique
et je voulais vous poser à ce sujet une
question vous
vous analysez de très nombreux des
centaines et des centaines de sites et
notamment vous analyser évidemment les
grandes plateformes
il me semble en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
nous a dit que les API des principales
plateformes les applications des
interfaces de programmation des des
grandes plateformes sont de nature et de
qualité variable et que si actuellement
des sites comme YouTube comme Facebook
etc ont des API qui sont loin loin
d'être parfaites mais qui sont
accessibles aux chercheurs ou sociétés
telles que la vôtre en revanche
Tik Tok ne dispose pratiquement d'aucune
API et par conséquent d'aucune façon
d'entrer à l'intérieur du du mécanisme y
compris pour les pour les chercheurs
est-ce que vous confirmez cela et ma
deuxième question c'est
quand vous parlez de confection
algorithmique est-ce que vous avez les
moyens à partir du moment où vous êtes
très internation réaliser sur ce sur ce
sujet
de savoir je voudrais poser la question
ou
est-ce que vous avez les moyens de
savoir où est produit ou son produit les
algorithmes il y a différentes sociétés
il y en a évidemment il y en a une par
pays pratiquement enfin en tout cas une
dans les dans les principaux pays est-ce
que c'est est-ce que vous êtes capable
de de localiser
si quelle est la part des algorithmes
qui sont produits en France par la
société française
gestétik France qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui est
global et par exemple fait en Chine ou à
Singapour
[Musique]
il est très très difficile pour ne pas
dire impossible d'accéder à l'algorithme
mais peut-être est-il encore plus
difficile d'accéder à la confection des
algorithmes et à l'origine de la
conviction est-ce que vous avez
là-dessus un certain nombre de
renseignements alors nous nous
n'étudions pas les algorithmes nous
sommes vraiment concentrés sur ces voilà
sur la présence des fausses informations
donc sur la sur les pillages je serai
pas même de vous donner des éléments
autre que ce que des chercheurs ont pu
me rapporter donc
voilà en revanche sur la seconde
question où son produit les algorithmes
quand on produit nos rapports on pose
toujours des questions aux plateformes
donc par exemple le rapport où on a
sorti ce chiffre de 20% on a posé de
nombreuses questions à TikTok au sujet
des algorithmes très précisément et
alors pas sur la localisation où ils
sont produits mais notamment est-ce que
les algorithme sont produits pour
l'algorithme de recherche pour empêcher
la promotion la valorisation des
contenus faux Tik Tok comme souvent
c'est le cas avec les grandes
plateformes ne nous a pas répondu dans
le détail à nos questions mais nous a
répondu par un commentaire général sur
leur règle d'utilisation et le fait que
les contenus faux trompeurs la més
information dangereuse était interdite
sur la plateforme ce qui se trouve ce
qui arrive souvent c'est que quand nous
publions un rapport Tik Tok va ensuite
supprimer les contenus qui étaient
signalé dans notre rapport supprimer des
hashtags entiers mais nous n'avons pas
de réponse sur la raison pour laquelle
ces contenus ont été promus dans des
résultats de recherche ou sur les films
for you des utilisateurs
merci en dehors des algorithmes est-ce
que vous avez une une vision de la façon
dont TikTok organise sa modération
et notamment de des modérateurs humains
oui alors sur la sur la modération alors
je n'ai pas de d'éléments précis
d'expertise sur la manière dont la
modération est organisée
autre que les rapports de presse que
vous connaissez aussi bien que moi
en revanche
ce qui est sûr c'est que ce qu'on sait
c'est en tout cas ce que TikTok dit
c'est que la modération sur la
plateforme repose d'abord sur un examen
des vidéos via l'intelligence
artificielle
puis s'il y a elle va détecter un
problème là la vidéo va être soit
supprimée soit envoyé un modérateur
humain pour une autre analyse
aurons on le sait lia elle est très
efficace pour repérer les contenus
haineux les contenus violents
les contenus racistes elle est beaucoup
moins efficace pour repérer la més
information et la désinformation
pourquoi parce que ça ressemble à de
l'actualité crédible
et donc effectivement là il y a un
problème fondamental et si on regarde
les chiffres selon les le rapport
d'application des règles communautaires
de Tik Tok qui est disp en ligne lors du
premier trimestre de 2022 Tik Tok a
retiré plus de 102 millions de vidéos
qui allaient à l'encontre de ces règles
communautaires mais sur ces 102 millions
de vidéos moins de 1%
ont été retirés car elle contrevenaient
aux règles d'intégrité et d'authenticité
qui comprennent la mes informations
dangereuses c'est très peu et pourquoi
sans doute parce que malheureusement
Liam n'est pas à la plus efficace pour
aller repérer ses contenus c'est pour ça
que nous chez nous chez newsgard nous
travaillons avec une équipe de
journalistes qui va passer énormément de
temps à analyser les contenus parce que
malheureusement effectivement les
campagnes de dessin formation efficaces
elle ressemble très pour trait a de
l'information
crédible notamment parce que aujourd'hui
si vous parlez de propagande qu'est-ce
qui va différencier un contenu de
propagande d'un contenu d'un média
fiable c'est tout simplement la personne
qui va être le l'initiateur du contenu
qui va avoir produit le contenu alors si
vous ne savez pas qui a produit ce
contenu et que cette personne se cache
derrière une un compte anonyme c'est
bien va bien être incapable d'identifier
ce contenu comme de la propagande d'État
vous disiez 1% concernant la mes
informations les 99 autres % en gros il
se répartissent comment alors ça j'ai
pas le détail mais sur les sur les
règles communautaires il va y avoir les
contenus violents tous les contenus
illégaux en fait illicitent qui sont
interdits sur la plateforme et donc les
1% ce n'est même pas que la més
information dangereuses c'est
l'intégrité et l'authenticité donc ça
inclut la mes informations dangereuses
mais ça va aussi inclure les contenus
générés paria les contenus et qui vont
être trompeurs les contenus authentiques
vous disiez que Tik Tok ne recourez pas
la labellisation de l'information
qu'en est-il des autres plateformes
alors ils le font mais peu et de manière
assez inégale ce qui est le cas sur
l'ensemble des plateformes je ne pense
pas que TikTok soit différent des autres
plateformes à ce niveau-là
souvent ce qu'on va remarquer c'est que
certains toutes les plateformes en
général ont des partenariats avec des
factures comme l'AFP en France et donc
certains contenus vont être labellisés
comme faux ou alors il va y avoir pour
tous les contenus ce qu'on a vu beaucoup
sur le covid-19 sur TikTok c'est que les
contenus qui traitaient du covid-19 il y
avait un label un interpellant pas
nécessairement sur la le peu de
fiabilité du contenu mais appelant à
aller chercher des sources fiables sur
le covid-19 ce qui déjà en soi est un
premier pas
ce qui se passe sur la labellisation du
contenu souvent c'est qu'on va avoir
certains contenus qui vont être
labellisés comme faux ou trompeur et
d'autres contenus sur le même mythe la
même fausse information ne vont pas
l'être parce que on va avoir un autre
vocabulaire qui va être utilisé tout
simplement ça va avoir échappé à la
plateforme donc s'il y a comme ça une
labellisation qui est assez inégale et
ça c'est le cas sur toutes les
plateformes le problème sur TikTok je
pense ce qui est certain c'est que il y
a peu de labellisation il y en a mais
mais elle est le design même de
l'application fait qu'encore une fois
quand vous scrolez d'une vidéo à une
autre c'est beaucoup plus facile de
passer à côté et de ne pas et de ne pas
percevoir ces c'est la belle parfois
aussi ce qu'on observe et on l'a observé
là récemment sur les contenus générés
par Liam en théorie donc c'est
obligatoire déjà même si je viens de
lire ce matin que y réfléchissait un
nouveau label justement pour les
contenus altérés Tik Tok c'est en
théorie déjà obligatoire de labelliser
d'indiquer que le contenu est altéré et
produit par lia mais ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on a de nombreuses vidéos que
nous nous avons vu notamment qui vont
être des vidéos altérées de Joe Biden
depuis sa son annonce qu'il va être
candidat à sa réélection
où le label va apparaître en milieu de
vidéo alors on sait que les utilisateurs
de Tik Tok vont scroller passer d'une
idée à l'autre donc là l'effet est assez
mitigé
ça coûte pas
y revenir ça coûte pas plus cher de le
mettre sur l'intégralité de la vidéo
plutôt qu'au milieu donc ça montre même
une volonté alors ce label il peut être
il est il est il peut être mis aussi par
par le créateur de contenu lui-même mais
si le créateur de contenu choisi de le
mettre en milieu ou en fin de vidéo
peut-être que c'est parce qu'il a
remarqué que le contenu allait être
moins partagé s'il le mettait en début
de vidéo là encore il s'agit de
supputation je n'ai pas de réponse mais
le fait est que la labilisation n'est
pas parfaite sur les contenus altérés à
ce jour
et d'ailleurs ce qui explique que Tik
Tok est annoncé être en train de
réfléchir à une à une nouvelle
labellisation pour être tout à fait
honnête c'est une problématique
qui est très compliqué et à laquelle
toutes les plateformes réfléchissent en
ce moment
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez des
détails sur le programme de checking
initiés par Tik Tok en Asie Pacifique
qui s'appuie sur lifep est-ce que il
existe dans d'autres continents non j'ai
pas du tout d'informations nous on est
on n'est pas des facts checker en tant
que tel au sens où on va produire nos
propres fact checking pour nourrir nos
analyses de sites et pour nourrir ce
cette base de données des principales
infox qui circulent en ligne mais
le fac on n'est pas des facts checker en
soi on a un travail un peu un petit peu
différent et donc on n'est pas du tout
dans ses partenariats de on n'est pas du
tout impliqué dans ce genre de
partenariat donc en l'occurrence je ne
sais pas exactement ce que l'AFP fait
avec eux ce qui est sûr c'est que
ces partenariats avec des factures ils
sont utiles
mais en général ils aident mais ils ne
sont pas à même de pleinement résoudre
le problème pour ce que je vous
décrivais juste avant c'est à dire qu'on
va voir certains contenus qui vont être
labellisés grâce à des fact checks
d'autres qui vont échapper parce que la
manière de présenter la fausse
allégation est différente et donc pas
repérer par la plateforme
donc c'est c'est important c'est bien
c'est utile ça peut pas être l'alpha et
l'oméga de la réponse des plateformes à
cette problématique
merci bien j'ai éventuellement d'autres
questions mais je voudrais pas utiliser
la parole je sais pas signalez-vous si
il y a des questions
[Musique]
le travail n'est pas fait par exemple
sur reconnaît tous des gens qui passent
des heures et des heures sur Facebook ou
sur YouTube à mal s'informer
quel est le quel est le quel est le
degré quelle est l'échelle différente
entre tip-top et ces autres plateformes
sur lesquels les gens s'informent entre
guillemets beaucoup alors
je pense d'abord qu'il faut être très
clair sur le fait que le risque zéro
n'existe pas
quand on parle de la diffusion de
fausses informations sur les réseaux
exact et que l'objectif donc de 0
contenu faux est impossible et n'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut attendre des
plateformes
ce qu'on peut en revanche et doit
demander c'est davantage de transparence
avec notamment une labellisation des
sources et des contenus qui circulent
pour que les utilisateurs retrouvent du
pouvoir là où les algorithmes décident
aujourd'hui à leur place finalement et
leur donne à voir des contenus dont ils
ignorent souvent l'origine
il faut aussi davantage de transparence
algorithmique c'est sûr et je pense que
[Musique]
sans comparer statistiquement
puisque encore une fois on n'a pas assez
de transparence et de données qui nous
permettent de le faire sur la portée des
fausses informations sur telle
plateforme en comparaison avec telle
plateforme le fait est que des fausses
informations on en trouve sur toutes les
plateformes le fait est tout de même que
[Musique]
il y a une forte présence de contenu
faux dans les résultats de recherche et
dans le scroll sur Tik Tok et je pense
que c'est d'une part du à l'algorithme
qui a tendance à valoriser l'engagement
donc les contenus faisant plus réagir et
on le sait les contenus faux font plus
réagir à la fois parce que ça entraîne
de l'adhésion de certaines personnes qui
y croient mais aussi d'autres des
personnes qui vont les rejeter qui vont
plus commenter pour dire non c'est faux
et puis parce que la modération sur la
plateforme
repose comme je le disais d'abord sur un
examen des vidéos par intelligence
artificielle qui a tendance à ne pas
être très efficace
sur ce sujet là donc je pense que que la
différence c'est peut-être dans le fait
que le encore une fois Tik Tok par
design est vraiment régie autour de ces
algorithmes vous n'avez vous ne pouvez
pas aller voir le enfin les gens ne vont
pas aller sur Tik Tok pour voir le
profil d'un ami ou c'est pas vraiment
comme ça qu'on consomme l'information
sur TiK ToK on consomme l'information en
regardant ce que nous propose
l'algorithme qui apprend à nous
connaître et nous propose des choses en
fonction de ce qu'ils pensent nous
plaire ou en faisant des recherches où
là encore c'est le moteur de recherche
l'algorithme qui va nous proposer des
sujets donc effectivement
de ce qu'on sait de l'algorithme mais là
encore une fois je ne suis pas une
spécialiste de ce qu'on sait qui est
sorti dans la presse on sait que
l'algorithme va valoriser effectivement
le temps de rétention sur les contenus
l'engagement etc qui sont autant de
choses qui vont avoir tendance à
promouvoir des contenus problématiques
deux deux petites questions
quand vous vous adressez à YouTube
Twitter que sais-je ou une autre
plateforme pour leur demander pour leur
signaler un problème leur demander des
informations
les échanges je sais pas comment vous
vous connaissez
comment on dit sur les réseaux dans la
vraie vie ou c'est un échange de de
courrier c'est très formel
est-ce que vous connaissez des
représentants de Twitter France ou
Europe avec qui vous discutez de tout ça
alors Twitter en ce moment c'est une
autre histoire de parler
de bon exemple
nous quand nous produisons un rapport
nous allons tous sur Tik Tok par exemple
mais nous avons fait des rapports sur
Twitter nous avons fait des rapports sur
sur facebook
quand nous produisons un rapport qui
concerne une plateforme nous allons
recontacter les représentants presse de
cette plateforme qui vont nous répondre
et en général prendre des mesures par
rapport du contenu qu'on va signaler
comme tout journaliste finalement nous
après nous comme je le disais nous
sommes signataires du Code de bonnes
pratiques de l'Union européenne contre
la désinformation
et dans ce cadre nous avons des réunions
avec
différents acteurs où nous pouvons
échanger nous produisons des rapports de
transparence comme les plateformes
peuvent produire des rapports de
transparence et je pense que
effectivement aujourd'hui le principal
conseil pour les plateformes puisque le
risque zéro n'existe pas mais que ce
qu'il faudrait essayer de faire c'est
davantage de transparence davantage de
c'est discuter davantage avec des
experts comme nous avec des facts shaker
avec des échangés des bonnes pratiques
et donc des lieux d'échanges comme comme
souhaite le faire ce code de l'Union
européenne avec ce Code de bonnes
pratiques qui est encore une fois sur la
base du volontariat
c'est une bonne chose et je pense qu'il
faudrait plus de lieux effectivement
d'échanges comme cela alors deuxième
question qui connaissez-vous chez TikTok
qui est-ce que vous voyez en vrai qui
vous répond est-ce qu'il participe à ces
réunions là parce que vous avez un nom à
votre
je n'ai pas de nom et
non mais est-ce que vous sauriez est-ce
que vous vous connaissez
qui sont là pour répondre aux questions
de la presse et qui le font de manière
tout à fait comme ailleurs tout à fait
oui oui tout à fait avec beaucoup de
effectivement là on a encore cette
semaine signaler des contenus
pour un rapport sur des contenus altérés
comme je vous le j'en parlais juste
avant et Tik Tok a pris des mesures nous
a répondu a pris des mesures concernant
ces comptes donc non il y a des il y a
des gens qui travaillent chez Tik Tok
qui sont là qui répondent aux questions
des journalistes mais sur la proportion
constater plus importante qu'ailleurs
puisque vous avez confirmé que c'était
une différence vraiment de degrés
alors justement je notais tout à l'heure
que
ils ont 20% de mes informations ils vous
répondent
alors la réponse de alors Tik Tok sur
cette étude en particulier et bon il
s'agit pas de dire que c'est 20% à tout
moment en tout temps c'est une
expérience enfin menée en un temps au
thé peut-être que d'ailleurs les choses
se sont améliorées depuis
en l'occurrence TikTok avait
critiqué notre méthodologie
voilà sur le fond on n'avait pas eu
de véritables réponses hormis le fait
que effectivement les contenus que nous
leur avons présenté semblaient
contrevenir
aux règles communautaires c'est un coup
classique de de critiquer la
méthodologie parce que c'est comme par
exemple dans des échanges d'avocats où
on critique toujours la forme on passe
des pages et des pages là-dessus avant
d'aller sur le fond ou c'est tip-top qui
vous critiquent la méthodologie et pas
les autres
ça arrive communément et peut-être que
leurs critiques sont légitimes encore
une fois je pense pas qu'il y ait de
mauvaises intentions en tout cas je ne
prêterai pas de mauvaises intentions
derrière les réponses qu'a pu nous faire
TikTok
nous avons toujours pu avoir des
réponses à nos rapports ils ont pris des
mesures quand des mesures étaient
possibles le problème est que ce sont
des mesures prises à posteriori quand
nous leur signalons des contenus
et puis donc il y a un problème de fait
sur la plateforme d'accord merci parce
que tu veux ou madame
2 ce qu'il y a d'autres collègues qui
souhaitent intervenir
d'abord je voulais féliciter notre
intervenant qui choisit plutôt
d'utiliser le mot infox que fake news
pour des questions de défense de la
langue française la francophonie et
c'est pas le président qui pourra me
contredire n'est-ce pas monsieur
le terme est beaucoup plus précis et il
offre toute la palette en fait comme
vous l'avez très bien décliné des
problématiques entre mes informations
des informations manipulations de
l'information et le président du Réseau
vous pose la question il y a des nuances
d'ailleurs je tiens à préciser qu'en
2018 lorsque le Sénat étudié la loi
bison a lutter contre la manipulation de
l'information il a eu ce débat de
repréciser de redonner des définitions
de chaque terme pour légiférer de
manière appropriée sur le le phénomène
alors ma question justement porte sur
la désinformation la manipulation de la
formation et la més information toutes
ces nuances est-ce que vous recherchent
vous permettent d'établir ce qui relève
de la més information peut-être une
expression naïve d'utilisateurs lambda
de jeunes qui véhiculent voilà des des
informations
par déficit de connaissance sans
interaction malveillante des
utilisateurs qui au contraire pour être
aussi des profils anonymes qu'on
identifier qu'on identifierait pour
essayer de canaliser le phénomène
personnellement je suis pas utilisatrice
de TikTok je l'ai pas volontaire pour
télécharger donc j'ai du mal à avoir la
différence par exemple avec une
application telle que Instagram il me
semble quand même que sur ces
applications il y a aussi des contenus
qui résultent tout simplement bonne
maintenant de l'utilisateur Lamb donc
qui porte une forme de responsabilité
avant de d'imaginer qu'il y a des
manipulations
importantes voilà ma question oui bien
sûr tout à fait et c'est pour ça que je
disais en préambule que nous regardons à
la fois la mes informations et la
désinformation et que parfois c'est tout
simplement impossible de savoir de quoi
relève une infox qui va devenir virale
si il y avait un acteur derrière dans
les questions qui m'avaient adressé vous
justement me poser la question de
l'attribution des fausses informations
est-ce qu'on arrive à attribuer à
trouver l'émetteur originel d'une fausse
information c'est l'étape la plus
complexe et c'est parfois impossible
quand on travaille sur sur la mes
informations à la désinformation
et souvent on va vouloir attribuer un
récit à un pays ou à une organisation en
particulier mais le fait que
les infox même s'ils émanent de payer
étrangers
de pays étrangers ou de colporteur d'un
Fox locaux
elle s'entremêle et finalement
les deux vont se mélanger donc je
m'explique une fausse information par
exemple promue par des bottes russes en
anglais
va pouvoir ensuite être reprise par des
colporteurs d'un Fox locaux en Italie
juste parce qu'il trouve cette
information intéressante il y a pas
d'utilisation de bottes il y a pas de
réseau ou d'organisation derrière cette
personne qui va contribuer à la vérité
et qui va peut-être donner le coup de
pouce qui va faire de cette infox
une quelque chose d'explosif et de très
populaire en ligne de la même façon un
État étranger va pouvoir
[Musique]
et là j'ai peur de faire un anglicisme
transformé en transformer en arme on a
ce terme de weponize en anglais qui est
souvent bien bien utile faire d'une arme
une et se servir pour ses propres
dessins euh d'une infox qui va en fait
émaner d'un compte d'un utilisateur
lambda qui a juste sorti une information
en maison ça peut être en més
interprétant des données avec bonne foi
et en diffusant cette info en pensant
avoir trouvé un scoop incroyable
donc les deux
s'entremêlent et effectivement c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je pense que
j'avais fait une intervention au
Parlement européen on m'avait demandé de
parler de la désinformation d'État
provenant de l'étranger et tout le
propos de mon propos était de dire que
il ne fallait pas séparer comme des deux
choses différentes la désinformation
étrangères et la més information des
informations pouvant provenir de
colporteur d'un Fox locaux dans
différents pays d'Europe parce que
finalement tous ces tous ces tous ces
différents acteurs se lisent les uns les
autres se reprennent les uns les autres
utilise
les uns et les autres à leur propre
dessin on l'a vu quand dans des
campagnes
semblant étatique finalement essayé de
se servir d'influenceurs locaux dans des
pays pour faire promouvoir des enfants
donc effectivement quand on parle de
fausses informations sur Tik Tok il
s'agit pas de pour il s'agit pas de
propagande nécessairement de
désinformation il s'agit de fausses
informations qui circulent la
qualification et l'attribution des
récifs faux c'est très compliqué on
arrive à le faire parfois quand une
c'est facile quand une information
provient d'un média d'État étranger qui
est clairement connu comme tel mais
c'est souvent compliqué en fait
donc j'ai l'impression que vous exercez
une sorte de mission de service public
en faisant cette surveillance des
contenus je voulais savoir quand vous
repérez donc un contenu vous écrivez et
vous dites entre guillemets que vous
êtes obéi finalement puisque Tik Tok va
enlever un contenu que vous aurez
ou alors j'ai mal compris
au sens où nous on n'a pas de position
sur que faire de ces contenus
observations et on les transmet parce
que en tant que journaliste on est
obligé de transmettre nos conclusions
aux personnes sur lesquelles on écrit
donc on les transmet le fait que très
souvent effectivement
beaucoup des contenus dont je parlais
sur les différents rapports sur Tik Tok
ont été retirés notamment un rapport
dont je n'ai pas parlé était un rapport
qui mettait en exergue la forte présence
de contenu
glorifiant les les exactions du groupe
Wagner
du groupe paramilitaire Wagner
ces contenus étaient très clairement en
violation des règles d'utilisation de
Tik Tok puisque c'était des contenus
appelants à la violence ou glorifiant la
violence tous les hashtags quasiment que
nous avons signalé ont été supprimés à
la suite de la publication de ce rapport
mais c'est pas qu'on a été obéi au sens
où on a rien demandé
à part de moi c'est un peu provocateur
j'en étais tout à fait content que que
ces contenus avec un caractère un peu
particulier soit retiré je voulais
savoir si vous aviez des concurrents
dans ce domaine s'il y avait d'autres
journalistes comme vous qui qui exercent
la même chose parce que
si c'est une bonne chose il faut espérer
que que vous êtes nombreux est-ce que
l'arcom aussi qui est une sorte de
gendarme de l'audiovisuel exactement la
même mission que vous et vous vous êtes
rétribué et comment parce que Tik Tok si
vous
arrivant à enlever le contenu c'est à
dire considère que vous avez été lanceur
d'alerte il faut bien que vous que vous
payez des gens pour surveiller tout ça
alors comment ça commence à se passe
alors oui donc
Tic-Toc pourrait être un client et nous
permet et nous payer pour utiliser nos
données aujourd'hui technoc n'est pas un
client je répète on n'a pas de lien
d'intérêt mais ça c'est comme ça que
nous nous payons nous vendons des
licences d'accès à différents acteurs
que ce soit des plateformes digitales
des réseaux sociaux des agrégateurs de
contenu
qui peuvent à la fois
se servir de nos données dans leur
travail de modération des contenus qui
peuvent intégrer nos analyses de la
fiabilité des sites
pour leurs utilisateurs pour leur donner
ce supplément d'informations sur les
sources qui circulent
et nous fournissons aussi des briefings
sur les tendances de la désinformation à
nos à nos clients donc effectivement
parmi nos clients nous avons toutes les
plateformes plus ou moins grande des
agrégateurs de contenu je le disais des
chercheurs le monde de la publicité
aussi qui est de plus en plus concernée
par cette problématique puisque l'un des
l'un des aspects dont nous n'avons pas
parlé mais qui est important aussi c'est
le fait que aujourd'hui une grande
partie de des fausses informations soit
financées par la publicité
programmatique notamment donc les
annonceurs se saisissent de cette de
cette problématique aussi et j'ai oublié
le début de votre question veuillez
m'excuser
ah oui si on a des concurrents donc il y
a beaucoup de fac checker et il y a de
qui font donc du fact checking pour un
média et qui ont en général des
partenariats donc des liens d'intérêt
avec les plateformes
nous notre travail encore une fois est
un petit peu
un pas de côté puisque nous faisons nous
produisons des des évaluations de la
fiabilité des sites d'information
journalistique et apolitique en fonction
de critères journalistiques de base
ça nous sommes les seuls à faire simple
le en revanche sur le fact checking qui
est une partie de notre travail sur
lequel nous appuyons nos analyses il y a
beaucoup de facteurs checker et nous
avons aussi des il y a de plus en plus
d'acteurs qui vont produire des des
listes de sites à risque des
informations personnelles
qui peuvent être considérés comme des
comme des compétiteurs en quelque
c'est un petit peu différent au sens où
souvent s'il y a l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle et que nous
nous utilisons nous nous utilisons
vraiment une équipe de journalistes et
nous faisons des analyses manuelles dans
le cadre desquelles nous contactons les
sites pour leur demander des
commentaires nous les invitons à
progresser sur leur pratique pour
obtenir de meilleurs scores et nous
mettons à jour nos analyses en
permanence pour s'assurer qu'on ne va
pas
dire d'un site qu'il est peu fiable
alors qu'en fait il a changé ses
pratiques donc là dessus nous sommes un
petit peu unique dans le paysage mais je
pense qu'il y a aussi un tout un nouvel
écosystème qui est en train de se créer
face à une menace qui est beaucoup plus
grande qu'elle n'était il y a quelques
années
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
pour déjà ces nombreuses réponses aux
questions des collègues ma question
concernait votre modèle économique qui
vient de vous être posé est-ce que vous
avez alors je vais la compléter ce que
vous avez vocation à rester en justice
également est-ce que vous imaginez par
rapport à finalement des contenus qui
serait illicite est-ce que vous avez un
service juridique qui vous permettrait
finalement de d'avoir des sphères en
justice donc c'était la première
question après vous avez parlé du
développement du réseau Tik Tok est-ce
que le développement de ce réseau en
terme de de fréquentation a été
accompagnée d'un changement d'algorithme
par rapport à ces fausses informations
ça zafox ou cette mes informations et
est-ce que vous classez ces cette ces
infox par rubrique est-ce que puisque
vous avez parlé d'un public jeune
notamment est-ce que vous avez des
différentes
la classification à la fois sur des
sujets géopolitiques sur la santé sur
différents sujets qui pourraient être
plus ciblés que d'autres merci
alors par rapport à votre première
question non
nous sommes vraiment des journalistes
donc et notre notre sujet c'est les
fausses informations
ce qui en soit
à ma connaissance n'est pas tout à fait
ne correspond pas tout à fait au contenu
illicite mais c'est vraiment le sujet
qui nous habite ce qui fait que par
exemple dans nos analyses même si
parfois ça va se rejoindre et faire
partie de l'analyse en terme de
d'éducation médias de nécessité d'en
parler tout ce qui est publication de
contenu illicite qui peuvent être des
contenus racistes par exemple ce n'est
pas le sujet de notre étude nous
travaillons vraiment sur la publication
d'informations fausses en revanche ce
qui va peut-être nous distinguer de
certains acteurs c'est que
dans le domaine de la vérification des
faits on va parfois vérifier des faits
qui sont peut-être un petit peu exagérés
ou peut-être
pas très substances
pas très fondée mais avec un il y a
quand même un petit peu de réalité
derrière nous nous intéressons vraiment
aux informations qui sont fausses
complètement fausse complètement
trompeuse
ou sans fondement aucun
typiquement le fait que le 11 septembre
était n'était pas en attentat mais
Inside Job comme on dit
on peut pas vraiment prouver que c'est
faux mais on peut dire que c'est capable
il y a pas d'éléments prouvant que c'est
vrai du tout donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on va considérer mais c'est pour vous
dire que notre notre
rapport aux fausses allégations et très
notre exigence est assez haute on ne va
pas aller vérifier des informations qui
sont juste des propos un peu exagérés
d'hommes politiques ce genre de choses
on est vraiment dans l'alllégation fosse
le les exactions à bout de chats ont été
mis en scène ce genre de choses
est-ce qu'il y a eu un changement
d'algorithme je serais bien incapable de
vous le dire encore une fois parce qu'on
a peu d'éléments et que nous nous avons
les éléments qui paraissent dans la
presse qui sont rendus public ou qui
fuitent sur l'algorithme
mais donc je serai incapable de dire si
cela était le cas et ce qu'on classe les
infox par rubrique alors nous quand nous
quand nous publions des analyses de
sites d'information effectivement nous
allons
avoir des petits des petites alertes sur
différents types de contenus
problématiques donc on va cocher une
case si le site diffuse beaucoup de
contenus faux sur la santé des contenus
faux sur le covid-19 des contenus faux
sur
le changement climatique des contenus
faux sur la guerre en Ukraine des
contenus de type kiwanon etc donc on a
effectivement des rubriques comme ça des
classifications
de manière interne qui nous permettent
nous de pouvoir trier les sites qui vont
diffuser
tel type de contenu qui va permettre par
exemple aux chercheurs de pouvoir
regarder dans notre base de données tous
les sites qui vont diffuser des fausses
informations sur l'Ukraine
merci merci monsieur le Président vous
nous avez dit Madame que l'intelligence
artificielle n'était pas en capacité de
repérer une mes informations et des
informations et que seul l'humain était
capable de les détecter
quand vous faites un signalement donc
vous êtes écoutés en tout cas entendu en
tous les cas pouvez-vous vous savez vous
comment est traité le signalement fait
par un utilisateur à Tik Tok d'une
fausse information
dont je vois que vous m'entendez déjà ça
fait partie des exigences du nouveau du
nouveau de la nouvelle réglementation
européenne d'accord les plateformes vont
devoir justement mettre en place des
processus plus transparents pour les
utilisateurs pour savoir si leur contenu
sont modérés mais je serais bien
incapable de vous dire ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui je vous remercie
une dernière question il y a deux trois
ans pardon
de ma part
il y a deux trois ans sur Shadows
professeur Harvard d'établissait que les
plateformes américaines puisque c'était
l'objet de son étude leur modèle
économique était toxiqué et pervers et
c'est ce qui publicitait gratuité qui
est rémunérateurs c'est ce qui tombait à
promouvoir les fausses nouvelles elle a
des informations la montée en puissance
des contenus et deux des radicalité etc
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de similaire et de
différents dans le modèle économique
d'une plateforme comme TikTok de vos
observations qui pourraient établir que
ça fait partie des causes
du déploiement de cette désinformation
sur en ligne et de la manipulation des
utilisateurs
sur le modèle d'affaires de Tik Tok
honnêtement je n'ai pas d'expertise
particulière ce que j'en connais je
pense correspond à ce que vous en
connaissez en lisant la presse
j'ai effectivement le livre dont vous
parlez de shoshanasu BOV qui est
excellent mais qui parle de quelque
chose qui n'est pas tout à fait mon
sujet c'est à dire la captation des
données d'utilisateur et le ciblage
publicitaire
c'est quand même ce qui contribue à
faire monter en puissance
avec des algorithmes les algorithmes
fonctionnent aussi avec les données la
désinformation la manipulation de la
formation donc je voulais juste avoir
votre regard sur ce que vous avez
observé du fonctionnement de ces
plateformes en général donc la
plateforme chinoise pour démonter
complètement le mécanisme voilà c'est
s'il y avait une vraie différence la
question est pertinente et je j'ai
évidemment un avis sur la question mais
je n'ai pas d'expertise donc je préfère
pas me prononcer sur la question
est-ce que
[Musique]
des choses qui sont exigées qui vont
donc être de sans doute être mise en
place ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
constate nous on a une équipe qui
travaille nous sommes présents dans 9
pays et nous couvrons plusieurs langues
que sont l'anglais le français l'italien
et l'allemand
est-ce que nous observons c'est
qu'effectivement la modération mais là
je parle pas de Tik Tok spécifiquement
mais dans sur toutes les plateformes et
souvent beaucoup plus efficaces et
existantes en anglais que dans les
autres langues et encore je vous parle
de langue européenne dans des pays où
les plateformes sont très présentes
nous savons que dans les pays d'Europe
de l'Est notamment il y a des
problématiques liées à l'absence
d'équipe de modération dans ces langues
là mais ça fait partie des chantiers qui
vont être mis en oeuvre par toutes les
plateformes encore une fois j'ai pas de
connaissances particulières liées à
l'équipe de modération Tik Tok mon
commentaire est plutôt général à toutes
les plateformes qui nous devons être
amenés à développer dans les autres
langues européennes ça m'amène vous
parler du DSA ça va mener une question
sur l'application du DSA dans votre
domaine celui de l'information de mes
informations est-ce que les
recommandations du DSA et qui vont
devenir des directives applicables
vous paraissent
adaptés au sujet
insuffisantes trop bureaucratique et
difficile à appliquer quel est votre
jugement
sur
l'état du DSA tel qui va être proposé
aux différentes
gouvernements et Parlement et notamment
au Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale en
France
nous nous sommes dans une position
particulière au sens où nous pouvons ça
et là à faire des recommandations mais
nous ne sommes pas ni des militants ni
des activistes nous sommes des
journalistes qui faisons des
observations en produisant des rapports
et des données donc je ne me prononcerai
pas sur la validité du DSA dans son
ensemble tout ce que je peux dire c'est
que davantage de transparence notamment
sur les algorithmes
et toujours nécessaire et bienvenue et
peut effectivement améliorer les
capacités d'analyse
des chercheurs et des groupes comme le
nôtre
j'aurais une dernière question
est-ce que vous travaillez avec des
neuroscientifiques sur la question de
l'éducation aux médias
et faire attention aux infos soyez plus
jeunes et avec qui et voilà non
scientifique
c'est intéressant comme question et je
vois d'où vous venez
pour poser cette question même sur la
question des biais cognitifs voilà
non nous notre approche de l'éducation
aux médias nous y venons vraiment par un
tout petit pan modeste nous travaillons
avec les
nous avons un programme d'éducation
immédiat par lequel nous travaillons
avec les bibliothèques publiques ce qui
a énormément de choses qui sont faites
notamment en France dans les écoles il y
a vraiment beaucoup d'ateliers beaucoup
de choses qui sont faites par le Clémi
notamment en France et mais comme vous
le savez la question de l'éducation aux
médias ce n'est pas une question qui se
limite aux jeunes
elle concerne tous les est vraiment tout
le monde donc on a choisi de travailler
avec les bibliothèques justement pour
atteindre d'autres publics et essayer
d'atteindre plusieurs plusieurs groupes
d'âge donc ce que nous faisons encore
une fois de manière très humble c'est
juste d'offrir gratuitement l'accès à
notre extension de navigateur qui va
donc permettre aux internautes de voir
la fiabilité des sources lorsqu'il
naviguent sur Internet nous donnons cet
outil gratuitement aux bibliothèques
publiques qui le souhaitent et nous leur
proposons d'organiser des ateliers à la
fois pour leur bibliothécaire et pour
les utilisateurs où nous allons
enseigner notre méthodologie
d'évaluation de la fiabilité des sites
avec l'idée de de que notre extension de
navigateur peut à la fois servir de
béquilles d'outils quand on va naviguer
sur Internet pouvoir aller rapidement
avoir une réponse à son interrogation
est-ce que cette source est fiable ou
non mais aussi finalement créer servir
de avec la répétition de sorte de vaccin
contre la més information en permettant
aux internautes de créer des réflexes et
c'est ça que je pensais est important
aujourd'hui de créer des réflexes pour
se demander
est-ce que ce site est anonyme si oui
pourquoi est-ce que c'est est-ce que ça
cache un loup
et donc c'est dans cette optique là que
nous travaillons avec plus près de 900
bibliothèques dans le monde aujourd'hui
y a-t-il d'autres questions
s'il n'y en auriez-vous une remarque que
vous auriez absolument souhaité faire on
a fait le tour avec les questions
nous vous remercions beaucoup madame
merci infiniment bonne soirée